coinbase is the largest crypto exchange
in the united states they literally have
tens of millions of users but yesterday
at the super bowl they ran an ad they
paid 14 million dollars for a 60-second
ad that just had this color-changing qr
code that bounced around the screen for
a whole minute now normally these super
bowl ads they require people to spend
millions and millions of dollars and
have all these big creative teams work
to try to capture the attention of the
audience coinbase went much simpler than
that they just had the qr code bouncing
around but of course it worked coinbase
went from 186th in the app store to
number two they literally here on the
right side of this chart you can see had
a massive spike in popularity as they
rose to number two in the app store they
had a absolute insane amount of traffic
the chief product officer at coinbase is
reporting that 20 million users went to
the landing page in the first minute now
when those 20 million people got there
first they crashed the servers this is
more traffic than coinbase had ever seen
in their entire lifetime but the people
who did actually get through what they
saw was fifteen dollars for any new user
to go ahead and sign up for coinbase be
able to buy cryptocurrencies on their
platform and coinbase also was giving
away three million dollars to existing
users so if you start to count up how
much money coinbase was putting behind
this it's close to 20 million dollars in
total but that's okay because coinbase
had the most creative ad it's the ad
that everyone is talking about all over
the internet and ultimately coinbase is
driving mainstream adoption of bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies all it took was a
color-changing qr code to bounce around
on the screen for 60 seconds that's
pretty incredible 20 million people in
one minute all because of that qr code
coinbase is the largest us-based
exchange coinbase is now in the hearts
and minds of users around the world
after that commercial kudos to coinbase
and i hope that we see more creative
stuff like this from crypto companies
moving forward